clearly
the jury and the judge did not believe
amber hurt all right i'm not sure um if
you've heard about what happened with
elon musk
but you know this the second that he
came out with the fact that he's buying
twitter boom
you know media came out yeah elon musk
paid a flight attendant a quarter
million dollars
give him an hj
i don't know
right try to get to the moon so johnny
depp seems to be a false accusation of
domestic violence
um
elon musk seems to be false accusations
of
sexual misconduct then we talked about
lebron james becoming a millionaire he's
been
allegedly having affairs nothing's been
proven and now the latest crazy thing
out there there's a wnba player have you
heard this
who's granting and raving it's clearly
insane
that lebron james has been sex
trafficking her right like she's he
stole my money he uh if you google
lebron james
wnba sex traffic it'll come up she's
going insane clearly she's got some
major issues
but
i mean even trump love him or hate him
he dealt with a lot of allegations
high profile here he goes lebron james
stole all my money and trafficked me
former wnba all-star
cappy poindexter outrageously blames the
lakers mvp for reportedly her going
missing for two years and if you scroll
down i'm sure there's some her ranting
somewhere here play this a little bit
hit the volume
all right anyway she's just ranting and
rape i don't know if we can play that
don't play
i don't want anything to get canceled
but she's [ __ ] lebron he stole my
money he sex trafficked me insane
allegations i don't think anybody
believes that lebron is doing that i
don't think most people don't think why
is elon what's he doing like i don't
think that's later yeah according to the
judge and jury johnny dept in domestic
uh
abuse amber hurt so
how do you feel about the current state
of the media and men being guilty until
proven
innocent apparently
are are women becoming more believable
less believable with the believe all
women
current state of the
marketplace right now who has strong
feelings on this
go ahead there i would say that
we live in a time where where
once men once we start reaching a high
pinnacle once we start reaching the
lebron james inline and why not
you know things would definitely come
out the word works out out of nowhere
fake fake news or any
anything that's not true and whatnot and
in that same culture
we
we it's easier to demonize those men and
it's easier to bring down those men it's
easier to to uh hold them guilty
immediately
than actually going through the whole
trial like where they did with john so
much easier just cancel that's it he's
done it sorry buddy you're not the jack
sparrow anymore no more pirates of the
caribbean for you buddy
so
i
i i believe i believe that
yeah this is this is the state that that
our culture is in right now and um it's
it's ridiculous
it's uh uncalled for
anybody men have always been under
attack yeah i i'm going to family court
fighting for my kids
and i have custody of my kids but you
know they keep switching the judges so i
go into a family court you know just to
make sure you know
things are based on our responsibilities
and the judge automatically thinks that
the
wife or the woman of the children have
the kids
i had the kids the whole all all my kids
i've had residential customer kids all
until they're adults i i raised could
never ask for any child but remember one
time a latina judge she looked at me and
said you have custody kids your ex is
now giving you yes
how much child support would you like
because i can have the power to sign
your child support i said i don't want
any child support zero i don't know
anything
right she wants to help i'll ask her for
plane tickets for helping go so he can
see his mom but i want anything
from her right but automatically i'm
indeed as many times i went back same
case
different judge i'm always assumed
that the dad in court is the deadbeat
dad the deadbeat father horrible example
of a man
and and there's been a couple times
where i was in court where the kids were
assigned to them like hold up judge this
is not promotion this is not for up for
motion today this is called following
the constitution
you just can't order things around in
court if they're not promoting you just
can't dictate who needs to go to where
that needs to be a motion that needs to
be argued and you need data and facts so
therefore you can assign kids to what
hustle because until now they're with me
but in that one case
the kid the kids went with the mom
sounds like you've been to court so many
times you're a freaking lawyer at this
point
sorry judge there's a motion dismissed
according to constitution
okay but you're saying that men get
demonized and vilified
in court even i mean i i think what 80
percent of women initiated
we have to protect our women we got to
protect the wise and by the way as a
father too i'm biased as well
because some knucklehead might do
something to my daughter i oh i mean
want to attack that dude without
realizing hey
my
women and my family potentially could be
followed this is why when i asked you
who has it tougher men and women you're
like men
because you've been inside of a
courtroom on like that
gotcha yeah jory
are men under attack these days are high
value men more under attack these days
well one that's the thing these people
are not high value people and we are
once again well there's people that we
were that were seeing johnny depp lebron
james uh elon musk that's as high value
as it gets i mean girls stop playing
they have anything what is the value
stop it what good-looking attractive
success
that will lead you in the direction they
try to get you to say anybody to lead me
okay
a person who has three four different
baby mamas that person is confused
they're they're not maybe they have
three for baby
what i'm not gonna allow is for my child
to be ruined why because i'm [ __ ] up
on the on the choice that i'm picking up
a man no
and this is what we're doing
females
are picking this man only because of
money
right which is these people are not high
value only because they have money this
is what i want you guys to understand
correct just because you have money that
does not make you happy
man in your opinion in my opinion i told
you the way you have raised your family
what type of product have you brought
into this world what is your child doing
but there's no evidence that lebron's
not a good father all his kids are doing
great johnny depp the first thing he
talked about when he came let me tell
you
hear me out
he said
i care about my children i mean elon
musk has kids there are alien names
whatever but he seems to be a father
good father so just because they're rich
and successful doesn't mean they're not
good fathers no not at all it does not
mean they're good fathers but they
[ __ ] up their children to begin with
because if they took accountability to
begin with yes if they were accountable
of what they were doing they wouldn't
just
choose this woman who is ruining them
they would be choosing women who is
going to respect their children so if
you did not respect your children no
somebody else is not going to respect
your children but back to the but back
to the original question is
these are allegations from other outside
women i wouldn't be surprised if it's
actually true because these people have
money they can do anything they want so
i'm not saying these are really these
are crazy allegations i'm just saying i
don't believe anything that's going on
in this world everything you hear it's
something to keep me distracted and no
i'm not going to pay attention i'm not
going to listen to this high value men
because they are not high value they're
actually this
you know especially lebron james what is
it doing for the black communities i
know i'm going to have a lot i'm going
to get a lot of heat for this because oh
he's building schools he's doing this
and he's doing that but he's actually
separating the black community fighting
between one another so this is deeper
and this is the conversation community
well this is a conversation for what so
be called the conspiracy theory for
later on and again
this is what i'm trying to tell you just
because you are
having money and have the huge following
doesn't mean you're actually high value
you are just here to distract the
population from actually what is going
on and he's distracting the black
community from what's going on
i don't think he's distracting his
community at all i think he's
distracting his children that the
children are gonna be the community that
they're being raised in like
same thing i can say with dwayne wade
like with his children um messed up you
know confused
these people are not high value men they
are confused trying to trick you into
thinking
that they're high value
like i'm not who i'm that's not a person
who i would look up to you know and say
oh that's a high value person you know i
would say it's a high value person what
men would you say that you look up to
my father that's a very high value
outside of your day outside of my father
i don't know outside of any family i
truly don't look at anybody else there's
nobody you can say all right that's a
high value no because how do you pick a
husband
your boyfriend's got a high volume it's
high value to me because he has the same
qualities as my dad has and it's a high
value person and to me that's high value
how you respect other people obviously
how much money you make as well it has a
lot to do with how you're going to live
your life
but so is it part of being high value
because you just said that money
money is a part of it but it's not what
it is right there's more to it but money
does take apart when calling somebody
high value it allows you to be who you
are right because you are not worried
about anything else it's just
emergencies
maybe let's use the word successful
because there's everyone has different
definitions what i'm saying it's all
interpretations it's fun it's high value
because believe me the next door you're
going to definitely tell me that this
next person is not high value but he is
successful but back to the original
question here
these
do you believe that lebron james was sex
trafficking in this what wnba what i
don't know about that you know that's
okay i seriously don't know i would have
to read but i'm not just gonna ignore it
just quick answers yes or no
sex trafficking i would say no do you
believe that elon did something sexually
inappropriate on a plane yes or no
i seriously cannot tell you okay did you
believe that johnny depp beat his girl
no i i was with johnny but i'm sure he
had his own the original question was
are successful men or high value men
more at risk because the they are that i
agree that's the point that i'm trying
to get now why is why are they
because of all these movements all of
this female movements that we're trying
to have because of we want to be equal
with our men we are not equal to our men
so
these movements are making our word less
reliable why do you say that women are
not equal to their men because they're
not you're
you're totally different from anything
biologically
well black i think i think women are
equal just different
you know there's not equal
equal
people i think i think equal equal
rights equal with with uh well that's
what everybody has with with uh desire
equal with opportunity i think we were
equal with that of course we got we got
uh you gotta fight for it but i think
there's just a different role that when
women play that men play
different in that role that's what i
mean it's all equilibrium but i wouldn't
say it's um equality you know like it's
not the same it's the same role yeah
yeah i said which remember that yeah
fair enough
joey you're taking a lot of heat today
but you're having a hand
you are handling your own that's why can
we just take a quick 30 second break and
just say hey everyone dab each other up
everyone's friends here
[Music]